Heather and her girlfriend live with a cat named Sid. The girlfriend was always inventing these cute little affectionate nicknames for Sid, but never did that for Heather. She was always praising Sid and asking Heather to praise Sid, but never gave that kind of approval to Heather. If anything, she was kind of detached when it came to Heather. So, even though Sid was just a cat, against her will, against her better judgment, Heather started to get jealous.
希瑟和她的女友养了一只叫希德的猫。女友总是给希德取各种可爱亲昵的绰号，却从没对希瑟这样做过。她总是夸奖希德，还要希瑟也去夸奖它，却从不给予希瑟同样的认可。甚至可以说，在对待希瑟时，她显得有些冷淡。所以，尽管希德只是一只猫，但希瑟还是不由自主地、违背本意地产生了嫉妒。
I remember that I would sort of wake up in the morning, and I would hear her saying things like, you are so beautiful. You are a princess. Look at you. And, you know, as I opened my eyes, I realized that she was talking not to me, but to the cat.
我记得我早上醒来时，会听到她说这样的话：“你真漂亮，你是个小公主，看看你。”然后，当我睁开眼，我才意识到她不是在对我说话，而是在对那只猫说。
You felt like the third wheel.
你感觉自己像个多余的人。
Mm-hmm. You know, I know if there had been another woman, I would have compared myself to her physically, sort of, what does she look like? What kinds of things is my girlfriend attracted to that I could aspire to? You know, what personality traits. Is she funny? You know, but there was just-- I didn't know what it was about Sid. I mean, I could see that she was attractive as a cat, and I could see that she had this nonchalance that was beautiful. You know, she didn't seem to care, really, that she was loved. So those were things that I did think about really-- cultivating, even. But--
嗯。你知道，如果是有另一个女人存在，我肯定会在外貌上和她做比较，会想：她长什么样？我女友喜欢什么样的特质，我可以去追求吗？比如性格方面，她幽默吗？但面对希德，我完全不知道该怎么比。我看得出它作为一只猫很有魅力，我也看得出它那种美丽的淡漠感。它似乎真的不在乎自己是否被爱。所以，这些确实是我考虑过要去培养的特质。但是……
You thought that cultivating a nonchalance, and--
你觉得培养这种淡漠感，而且……
You know, that I was this concerned about it shows you that it would have been a, you know, a fake. But, yeah, I mean, I thought about cultivating it like that.
你知道，我竟然会为此如此担忧，这说明如果我真的那样做了，也会是虚假的。但没错，我确实想过要那样培养。
Since our pets win our love, they can also activate all the other feelings that can go with love-- jealousy, and anger, and dependence, and just everything else. And as soon as any one of those feelings kicks in, all the complicated dynamics that happen between any people, in any household, any family, all of those also inevitably kick in. And that's what happened with Heather and Sid the cat.
既然宠物赢得了我们的爱，它们也能激发出与爱相伴的其他所有感受——嫉妒、愤怒、依赖，以及其他一切。一旦这些感觉中任何一种出现，家庭或关系中人与人之间所有复杂的互动也会不可避免地产生。这就是希瑟和猫希德之间发生的事。
I felt sort of the same way I felt-- you know how when you have a crush on someone, and then you're friends with their significant other, and all the awkwardness as you pretend that, you know, you sort of don't have the feelings that you do for this other person. I sort of felt like Sid was the significant other of the person, you know, for whom I had feelings.
我的感觉和那差不多。你知道当你暗恋某人，又和他们的另一半是朋友时，那种尴尬感——你得假装自己对那个人没有那种特殊的感情。我当时就觉得希德就是我所爱之人的“另一半”。
And so I felt awkward around Sid, and I felt like I had to-- I don't know. I felt like they were together before I was around, and I was an interloper. You know, all the awkwardness surrounding that.
所以我面对希德时感到很尴尬，我觉得我必须……我不知道。我感觉在我在场之前他们就在一起了，而我是一个闯入者。你知道，围绕着这一切的尴尬。
And so what's it like to be in a love triangle with another woman and a cat?
那么，和一个女人还有一只猫陷入三角恋是什么感觉？
Well, it was pretty, you know, diminishing. I mean, it was a beautiful cat.
嗯，这让人感到挺……挺渺小的。毕竟，那是一只漂亮的猫。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, "In Dog We Trust," stories of dogs and cats and other pets, and how they get caught up in our family dynamics as non-speaking members of our households. Our program today in three acts. Act 1, "The Youth in Asia," in which writer David Sedaris describes how a Great Dane-- and not a very smart one-- was able to completely replace him and his sisters when they grew up and moved out of their parents' house.
这里是WBEZ芝加哥电台的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天节目的主题是“忠于狗”，讲述关于猫狗和其他宠物的故事，以及它们如何作为非言语成员融入我们的家庭动态。节目分为三幕。第一幕，“亚洲的青年”，作家大卫·塞达里斯描述了一只大丹犬——而且不是那种特别聪明的——是如何在他和姐妹们长大离家后，彻底取代了他们的位置。
Act 2, "Polly Wants So Much More Than a Cracker." Three small children who love their mom, but do not love their mom's pet bird.
第二幕，“波莉想要的不只是饼干”。三个爱妈妈却不爱妈妈那只宠物的孩子。
Act 3, "Resurrection." What it means in a family when a pet armadillo dies, and what it means when it doesn't die. Stay with us.
第三幕，“复活”。在家庭中，一只犰狳宠物的死去意味着什么，如果不死又意味着什么。请继续收听。
Act 1, "The Youth In Asia." So when a pet dies, to what degree can it be replaced by another pet? And to what degree can pets replace people in our lives?
第一幕，“亚洲的青年”。当一只宠物死去时，它能在多大程度上被另一只宠物取代？宠物又能在多大程度上取代我们生活中的人？
Well, David Sedaris has this story.
大卫·塞达里斯有这样一个故事。
In the early 1960s, during what my mother referred to as the tail end of the Lassie years, my parents were given two collies, which they named Rastus and Duchess. We were living, then, in New York State, out in the country, and the dogs were free to race through the forest. They napped in meadows, and stood knee-deep in frigid streams, co-stars in their own private dog food commercial.
20世纪60年代初，在我母亲所说的“莱西岁月”末期，父母得到了两只牧羊犬，取名拉斯图斯和杜chess。当时我们住在纽约州乡村，狗可以在森林里自由奔跑。它们在草地上打盹，站在冰凉的溪流中，仿佛是它们自己狗粮广告里的主角。
Late one January evening, while lying on a blanket in the garage, Duchess gave birth to a litter of slick, potato-sized puppies. When it looked as though one of them had died, our mother placed the creature in a casserole dish and popped it into the oven like the witch in Hansel and Gretel.
一月的一个深夜，杜chess躺在车库的毯子上生下了一窝滑溜溜、土豆大小的幼崽。当看起来其中一只已经死亡时，母亲把那个小家伙放进砂锅里，像《汉塞尔与格莱特》里的女巫一样把它塞进了烤箱。
Oh, keep your shirts on, she said. It's only set on 150. I'm not baking anyone. This is just to keep it warm. The heat revived the sick puppy, and left us believing that our mother was capable of resurrecting the dead.
“别大惊小怪，”她说，“温度才设在150度。我又不是在烤谁，这只是为了给它保暖。”热量让那只病弱的幼崽活了过来，让我们相信母亲有让人起死回生的能力。
Faced with the responsibilities of fatherhood, Rastus took off. The puppies were given away, and we moved south, where the heat and humidity worked against the best interests of a collie. Duchess's once beautiful coat now hung in ragged patches.
面对父亲的责任，拉斯图斯逃跑了。幼崽被送人了，我们搬到了南方，那里的高温和潮湿对牧羊犬非常不利。杜chess曾经美丽的皮毛现在变得东一块西一块。
When finally, full of worms, she collapsed in the ravine beside our house, we re-evaluated our mother's healing powers. The entire animal kingdom was beyond her scope. She could only resurrect the cute dead.
当它最终满身寄生虫倒在房子旁边的峡谷时，我们重新评估了母亲的治愈能力。整个动物界都超出了她的范畴，她只能复活可爱的死物。
The oven trick was performed on half a dozen dazed and chubby hamsters, but failed to work on my first guinea pig, who died after eating four cigarettes and an entire pack of matches. Don't take it too hard, my mother said, removing her oven mitts. The world is full of guinea pigs. You can get another one tomorrow.
烤箱戏法用在半打昏昏沉沉、胖乎乎的仓鼠身上也奏效过，但对我第一只豚鼠却没用，它在吃了四支香烟和一整盒火柴后死掉了。“别太难过，”母亲摘下烤箱手套说，“世界上到处都是豚鼠，你明天可以再买一只。”
Eulogies tended to be brief, our motto being there's always more where this one came from. A short time after Duchess died, our father came home with a German shepherd puppy.
悼词通常都很简短，我们的座右铭是“旧的不去，新的不来”。杜chess死后不久，父亲带回来一只德国牧羊犬幼崽。
For reasons that were never fully explained, the privilege of naming the dog went to a friend of my older sister's, a 14-year-old girl named Cindy. She was studying German at the time. And after carefully examining the puppy, and weighing it with her hands, she announced that it would be called Madchen, which apparently meant girl in what she referred to as Deutsch.
出于某种从未完全解释清楚的原因，给狗取名的特权落在了我姐姐的一个朋友身上，一个14岁的女孩叫辛迪。她当时正在学德语，仔细检查并掂量了那只小狗后，宣布它叫“Madchen”，在德语里似乎就是“女孩”的意思。
When she was six months old, Madchen was hit and killed by a car. Her food was still in the bowl when our father brought home an identical German shepherd. The same Cindy christened as Madchen II.
六个月大时，Madchen被车撞死了。父亲带回一只一模一样的德国牧羊犬时，它碗里的狗粮还没吃完。同一个辛迪又把它命名为“Madchen II”。
This tag team progression was disconcerting, especially for the new dog, who was expected to possess both the knowledge and the personality of her predecessor. Madchen I would never have wet on the floor like that, my father would scold, and the dog would sigh, knowing she was the canine equivalent of a rebound.
这种接力赛式的更替让人不安，尤其是对新来的狗，因为它被要求同时拥有前任的知识和性格。“Madchen I绝不会在地板上撒尿，”父亲会责备，而狗会叹气，因为它知道自己不过是狗界的“替代品”。
Madchen II never accompanied us to the beach, and rarely posed in any of the family photographs. Once her puppyhood was spent, we more or less lost interest. We ought to get a dog, we'd sometimes say, completely forgetting that we already had one.
Madchen II从没陪我们去过海滩，也很少出现在家庭合影中。等它的幼年期一过，我们就基本失去了兴趣。我们有时会说，“我们该养条狗了”，完全忘记了我们已经有一条了。
During the era of the Madchens, we had a succession of drowsy, secretive cats who seemed to share a unique bond with our mother. It's because I open their cans, she said. Though we all knew it ran deeper than that. What they had in common were their claws. That, and a deep-seated need to destroy my father's golf bags.
在Madchen时代，我们家有一连串昏昏欲睡、神神秘秘的猫，它们似乎和母亲有一种独特的纽带。“那是因为我给它们开罐头，”她说。尽管我们都知道缘由不止于此。它们共同之处在于它们的爪子，还有一种深入骨髓的、摧毁父亲高尔夫球包的需求。
The first cat passed into a disagreeable old age, and died hissing at the kitten who had prematurely arrived to replace her. When, at the age of nine, the second cat was diagnosed with feline leukemia, my mother was devastated. I'm going to have Sadie put to sleep, she said. It's for her own good, and I don't want to hear a word about it from any of you. This is hard enough as it is.
第一只猫在令人不快的衰老中离世，死前还在对着一只过早来到家里取代它的幼猫嘶吼。当第二只猫九岁时被诊断出患有猫白血病，母亲崩溃了。“我要让萨迪安乐死，”她说，“这是为它好，我不想听到你们任何人说三道四，这对我已经够难受的了。”
The cat was put down, and then came the anonymous postcards and phone calls orchestrated by my sisters and I. The cards announced a miraculous new cure for feline leukemia, while the callers identified themselves as representatives of Cat Fancy magazine. We'd like to use Sadie as our cover story, and we're hoping to schedule a photo shoot. Is tomorrow possible?
那只猫被处死了，接着便是我和姐妹们策划的匿名明信片和电话骚扰。卡片宣称有一种治愈猫白血病的奇迹疗法，而打电话的人则自称是《猫迷》杂志的代表。“我们想用萨迪做封面故事，希望能安排一次拍摄。明天可以吗？”
After spending a petless year with only one child still living at home, my parents visited a breeder, and returned with a Great Dane they named Melina. They loved this dog in proportion to its size, and soon their hearts had no room for anyone else. In terms of family, their six children had been nothing more than a failed experiment. Melina was the real thing. The dog was their first true common interest, and they loved it equally, each in their own way.
在仅剩一个孩子在家住了一年之后，父母去了一家养殖场，带回来一只叫梅琳娜的大丹犬。他们爱这只狗的程度与其体型成正比，很快他们的心就再也装不下其他人了。在家庭层面上，他们的六个孩子不过是一场失败的实验，梅琳娜才是真正的成就。这只狗成了他们第一个共同的真爱，他们以各自的方式同样宠爱它。
Our mother's love tended towards the horizontal, a pet being little more than a napping companion, something she could look at and say, that looks like a good idea. Scoot over, why don't you. A stranger peeking through the window might think that the two of them had entered a suicide pact. She and the dog sprawled like corpses, their limbs arranged into an eternal embrace.
母亲的爱倾向于“水平式”，宠物不过是一个打盹的伴侣，她看着它说：“看起来是个好主意，往那边挪挪。”一个从窗户窥视的陌生人可能会以为他们签了自杀协议——她和狗像尸体一样摊开，四肢交缠成永恒的拥抱。
My father loved the Great Dane for its size, and frequently took her on long, aimless drives, during which she'd stick her heavy, anvil-sized head out the window and leak great quantities of foamy saliva . Other drivers pointed and stared, rolling down their windows to shout, hey, you got a saddle for that thing?
父亲因为梅琳娜的体型而爱它，经常带它去漫无目的的长途驾驶。它会把那个沉重的、铁砧一样大的脑袋伸出窗外，淌下大量的泡沫唾液。其他司机指指点点，摇下窗户喊：“嘿，你给那玩意儿配个马鞍了吗？”
When out for a walk, there was the inevitable are you walking her, or is it the other way around? Our father always laughed as if this were the first time he'd heard it. The attention was addictive, and he enjoyed a pride of accomplishment he'd never felt with any of us. It was as if he were somehow responsible for her size and stature, as if he'd personally designed her spots, and trained her to grow to the size of a pony.
散步时，总会有人问：“是你溜它，还是它溜你？”父亲总是大笑，好像这是他第一次听到一样。这种关注令人上瘾，他获得了一种从未在我们身上感受到的成就感。仿佛是他一手设计了它的大小和体格，仿佛是他亲手设计了它的斑点，并训练它长到小马那么大。
When out with the dog, he carried a leash in one hand and a shovel in the other. Just in case, he said. Just in case, what, she dies and you need to bury her? I didn't get it. No, he'd say. It's for-- you know, it's for her business. My father was retired, but the dog had business.
遛狗时，他一手牵着绳子，一手拿着铲子。“以防万一，”他说。“以防万一什么？它死了你需要埋它？”我没明白。“不，”他说，“是为了……你知道，为了它的生意。”父亲退休了，但狗有“生意”。
I was living in Chicago when they first got Melina, and every time I came home, the animal was bigger. Every time, there were more Marmaduke cartooms displayed upon the refrigerator. And every time my voice grew louder as I asked myself, who are these people?
他们刚养梅琳娜时我住在芝加哥，每次回家这动物都变大了。冰箱上显示的《马马杜》漫画越来越多。我每次回家都大声问自己：这些人是谁？
Down, girl, my parents would chuckle as the puppy jumped up, panting for my attention. Her great padded paws reached my waist, then my chest and shoulders, until, eventually, her arms wrapped around my neck and her head towering above my own, she came to resemble a dance partner scouting the room for a better offer. That's just her way of saying hello, my mother would say, handing me the towel used to wipe up the dog's bubbling seepage. Here, you missed a spot on the back of your head.
“下去，乖女孩，”当幼犬跳起来渴望我的注意时，父母会轻笑。它巨大的肉垫爪子够到我的腰部，然后是胸口和肩膀，最终，当它双臂环住我的脖子，头高耸在我的头顶上方时，它看起来就像是在舞厅里寻找更好舞伴的舞者。“那是它打招呼的方式，”母亲会说，递给我用来擦拭狗流出的泡沫状液体的毛巾，“喏，你后脑勺那儿还有一块漏掉了。”
The dog's growth was monitored on a daily basis, and every small accomplishment was documented for later generations. One can find two pictures of my sister Tiffany, while Melina has entire volumes devoted to her Terrible Twos.
这只狗的成长被每日监测，每一个小小的成就都被记录下来留给后代。你可以找到两张我姐姐蒂芙尼的照片，而梅琳娜却有整整几卷关于它“可怕的两岁”的记录。
Hit me, my mother said on one of my returns home from Chicago. No, wait, let me go get my camera. She left the room and returned a few moments later. OK, she said, now hit me. Better yet, why don't you just pretend to hit me.
“打我，”我从芝加哥回家时母亲说，“不，等等，让我去拿相机。”她离开房间，几分钟后回来。“好了，”她说，“现在打我。或者更好，你假装打我。”
I raised my hand, and my mother cried out in pain. Ow, she yelled, somebody help me. This stranger is trying to hurt me, and I don't know why. I caught an advancing blur moving in from the left, and the next thing I knew, I was down on the ground, the Great Dane tearing holes in the neck of my sweater. The camera flashed, and my mother squealed with delight. God, I love that trick. I rolled over to protect my face. This isn't a trick. My mother snapped another picture. Oh, don't be so critical. It's close enough.
我举起手，母亲大声痛呼。“哎哟，”她叫道，“谁来帮帮我。这个陌生人想伤害我，我不知道为什么。”我看到左侧扑过来一个模糊的影子，下一秒我就被扑倒在地，那只大丹犬撕咬着我毛衣的领口。相机闪烁，母亲咯咯地笑着：“天哪，我爱这个把戏。”我翻身护住脸。“这根本不是把戏。”母亲又拍了一张。“噢，别太挑剔了，这样已经够逼真了。”
With us grown and out of the house, my sisters and I foolishly expected our parents' lives to stand still. They were supposed to stagnate and live in the past, but instead, they constructed a new we, consisting of Melina and the founding members of her fan club.
我们长大离家后，姐妹们和我天真地以为父母的生活会停滞不前。他们本该固守过去，但他们却构建了一个新的“我们”，由梅琳娜和它粉丝俱乐部的创始成员组成。
Someone who obviously didn't know her too well had given my mother a cheerful stuffed bear with a calico heart stitched onto its chest. According to the manufacturer, the bear's name was Mumbles, and all it needed in order to thrive were two AA batteries and a regular diet of hugs.
显然是一个不太了解的人给了母亲一只快乐的毛绒熊，胸前缝着一颗印花心。据制造商说，熊的名字叫“喃喃”，它只需要两节五号电池和定期的拥抱就能“茁壮成长”。
Where's Mumbles, my mother would ask, and the dog would jump up and snatch the bear from its hiding place on top of the refrigerator, yanking it this way and that in hopes of breaking its neck. That's my girl, my mother would say. We don't like Mumbles, do we?
“喃喃在哪儿？”母亲会问，然后狗就会跳起来，从冰箱顶部的藏身处把熊抢下来，为了折断它的脖子来回晃动。“好女孩，”母亲会说，“我们不喜欢喃喃，对吧？”
I learned that we liked Morley Safer, but not Mike Wallace, that we didn't like Mumbles or thunder, but we're crazy about Stan Getz records and the Iranian couple who'd moved in up the street. It was difficult to keep straight, but having known these people all my life, I didn't want to be left out of the we.
我得知我们喜欢莫利·塞弗，不喜欢迈克·华莱士；我们不喜欢喃喃，也不喜欢打雷；但我们对斯坦·盖茨的唱片和住在街上的那对伊朗夫妇情有独钟。这很难理清，但作为一个认识他们一生的人，我不想被排除在“我们”之外。
During the final years of Madchen II and the first half of the Melina epoch, I lived with a female cat named Neil. My mother looked after the cat when I moved from Raleigh, and flew her to Chicago once I'd found a place and settled in. Neil was old when she moved to Chicago, and then she got older.
在Madchen II时代后期和梅琳娜时代上半段，我养了一只叫尼尔的雌猫。我从罗利搬家时母亲照顾它，等我安顿好后它就飞到了芝加哥。尼尔搬到芝加哥时已经老了，然后又变得更老。
She started leaving teeth in her bowl, and developed the sort of breath that could remove paint. When she stopped cleaning herself, I took to bathing her in the sink, and she'd stand still, too weak to resist the humiliation of shampoo. Soaking wet, I could see just how thin and brittle she really was, almost comic, like one of those cartoon cats checking her fur coat at the cloakroom of the seafood restaurant.
它开始在碗里掉牙，口中呼出的气息足以剥落油漆。当它不再清洁自己时，我开始在水槽里给它洗澡。它会静静地站着，虚弱到无法抗拒洗发的屈辱。湿漉漉的它，我能看出它是多么消瘦和脆弱，简直滑稽，就像那些把皮毛大衣寄存在海鲜餐厅衣帽间的卡通猫。
Her kidneys shrank to the size of raisins, and though I loved her very much, I assumed the vet was joking when he suggested dialysis. I took her for a second opinion. Vet number two tested her blood, and phoned me at home, saying, perhaps you should think about euthanasia.
它的肾脏缩成了葡萄干大小，虽然我非常爱它，但当兽医建议透析时，我以为他在开玩笑。我带它去寻求第二意见。第二位兽医检测了它的血液，在家给我打来电话说：“也许你应该考虑安乐死。”
I hadn't heard that word in a while, and pictured scores of happy Japanese children spilling from the front door of their elementary school. Are you thinking about it, he asked? Yes, I said, as a matter of fact I am.
我有一段时间没听到这个词了，脑海里浮现出成群结队的快乐日本小孩从小学前门涌出的画面。“你在考虑吗？”他问。我说：“实际上，我确实在考虑。”
In the end, I returned to the animal hospital, and had her put to sleep. When the vet injected the sodium phenobarbital, Neil fluttered her eyes, assumed a apt position, and died.
最后，我回到了动物医院，让它接受了安乐死。当兽医注入戊巴比妥钠时，尼尔眨了眨眼，采取了一个恰当的姿势，然后死去。
A week after putting her to sleep, I received Neil's ashes in a forest green can. She'd never expressed any great interest in the outdoors, so I scattered her remains on the carpet-- --and then vacuumed her back up.
将它安乐死一周后，我收到了装在森林绿罐子里的尼尔的骨灰。它生前从未对户外表现出任何兴趣，所以我把它的遗骸洒在地毯上——然后又用吸尘器把它吸了回去。
The cat's death struck me as the end of an era. It was, of course, the end of her era. But with the death of a pet, there's always that urge to crowd the parentheses and string black crape over an entire 10- or 20-year period. The end of my safe college life, the last of my 30-inch waist, my faltering relationship with my first real boyfriend. I cried for it all, and spent the next several months wondering why so few songs were written about cats.
猫的死让我觉得一个时代的终结。当然，这是它的时代终结了。但在宠物死后，总有一种冲动想去填满括号，给整个十年或二十年的时期蒙上黑纱——我安全的大学生活的结束，我30英寸腰围的最后时光，我和第一个真正男朋友那摇摇欲坠的关系。我为这一切哭泣，并在接下来的几个月里纳闷，为什么关于猫的歌这么少。
My mother sent a consoling letter, along with a check to cover the cost of the cremation. In the left-hand corner, under the heading marked, memo, she'd written, pet burning. I had it coming.
母亲寄来一封慰问信，随信还有一张支票用于支付火化费用。在左下角，标有“备注”的标题下，她写着“宠物焚烧”。这真是我的“应得”。
When my mother died, Melina took over her side of the bed. Due to their size, Great Danes generally don't live very long. My father massaged her arthritic legs, carried her up the stairs, and lifted her into bed. He treated her the way that men in movies treat their ailing wives, the way he would have treated my mother had she allowed such naked displays of affection. Melina's parentheses contained the final 10 years of his married life. She'd attended my father's retirement, lived through my sister's wedding, and knew who everyone was talking about when they mentioned the M words-- Mom, Mumbles, and Morley Safer.
母亲去世后，梅琳娜接管了她那侧的床位。由于体型原因，大丹犬寿命通常不长。父亲按摩它患关节炎的腿，把它抱上楼，再抱上床。他对待它就像电影里男人对待生病的妻子一样，就像如果母亲允许这样露骨的亲昵，他也会那样对待母亲。梅琳娜的括号里包含了父亲婚后生活的最后十年。它出席了父亲的退休仪式，经历了姐姐的婚礼，当大家提到“M”开头的人——妈妈（Mom）、喃喃（Mumbles）和莫利·塞弗（Morley Safer）——时，它知道大家在说谁。
Regardless of her pain, my father could not bear to let her go. The youth in Asia begged him to end her life. [JAPANESE], they said. [JAPANESE] But he held out until the last minute.
无论它多么痛苦，父亲都无法忍受放手。“亚洲的青年”（Youth in Asia，谐音安乐死Euthanasia）乞求他结束它的生命。他们说：“安乐死”。但他坚持到了最后一刻。
A month after Melina died, my father returned to the breeder, and came home with another Great Dane, a female like Melina, gray spots like Melina, only this one is named Sophie. He tries to love her, but readily admits that he may have made a mistake. She's a nice enough dog, but the timing is off.
梅琳娜死后一个月，父亲回到养殖场，带回了另一只大丹犬，和梅琳娜一样的雌性，一样的灰斑，只是这一只叫苏菲。他试着去爱它，但很快承认他可能犯了个错误。它是一条不错的狗，但时机不对。
When walking the puppy through the neighborhood, my father feels not unlike the foolish widower stumbling behind his energetic young bride. Her stamina embarrasses him, as does her interest in younger men. The passing drivers slow to a stop and roll down their windows. Hey, they yell, are you walking her, or is it the other way around?
当牵着这只幼犬在社区散步时，父亲感觉自己就像个跟在精力充沛的新娘身后踉跄的傻老头。它的活力让他尴尬，它对年轻男性的兴趣也让他尴尬。路过的司机减速停下，摇下窗户。“嘿，”他们喊道，“是你溜它，还是它溜你？”
Their words remind him of happier times, of milder forces straining against the well-worn leash. He still gets the attention. But now, in response, he just lifts his shovel and groans.
他们的话提醒他过去的美好时光，提醒那些在磨损的牵引绳下挣扎的更温和的力量。他依然能获得关注，但现在，他只是举起铲子，痛苦地呻吟。
David Sedaris. This story "The Youth in Asia" is in his book Me Talk Pretty One Day. A version of the story also appeared in Esquire magazine. You can catch David on tour all over the country starting in April. Details at DavidSedarisBooks.com/tour.
大卫·塞达里斯。“亚洲的青年”这个故事收录在他的书《我说话漂亮的那一天》中。该故事的一个版本也出现在《时尚先生》杂志上。四月起，大卫将在全国各地巡回演出。详情见DavidSedarisBooks.com/tour。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐]
Act 2, "Polly Wants So Much More Than a Cracker."
第二幕，“波莉想要的不只是饼干”。
When Veronica tells this story, it's a story about love. When she was 17, she saw a bird in a pet store, a macaw, which is kind of a big parrot-- brightly colored, with a three-foot wingspan.
当维罗妮卡讲述这个故事时，这是一个关于爱的故事。17岁时，她在宠物店看到了一只鸟，一只金刚鹦鹉——那是一种很大的鹦鹉，颜色鲜艳，翼展三英尺。
And I fell in love with her immediately. And, you know, I was still in high school. I had no money whatsoever.
我立刻爱上了它。那时候我还在读高中，根本没有钱。
How expensive was she?
它有多贵？
Well, the price tag on the cage said $1,400, which was an inordinate amount of money.
笼子上的标签写着1400美元，那是一笔极其庞大的数目。
So how long did it take you to pay off the bird?
那你花了多久才把鸟钱还清？
It took me about five years to pay her off, working part-time jobs, babysitting.
我花了大约五年时间才还清，靠打零工和做保姆。
And what did you love about her? What was the thing that drew you to her?
你爱它什么？是什么吸引了你？
I find it hard to say, exactly, why I was drawn to her. I thought she was the most beautiful thing I'd ever seen. It's hard to describe how it feels to love an animal. But as soon as I saw her face, I just thought she was the most beautiful thing, and I had to have her, and I wanted to see that face every day, and I wanted to care for her. And I didn't know anything about bringing up parrots, or feeding them, or caring for them. I just wanted to take her home like a big-- like a treasure.
很难准确说出我为什么被它吸引。我觉得它是我见过最美的东西。爱上一只动物的感觉很难描述。但我一看到它的脸，就觉得它是最美的，我必须拥有它。我每天都想看到那张脸，想照顾它。我那时对养鹦鹉一无所知，不知道怎么喂养或照顾。我只想把它像个宝贝一样带回家。
OK. Fast-forward 23 years.
好的，时光快进23年。
When we first broadcast this story, Veronica was 40 years old, married with two twin boys, Kyle and Cameron, aged five, and another boy, Daniel, who was eight. One of the things she didn't know about parrots when she first saw her macaw is that they can live for 80 years-- 80. So every morning, she would take the bird, whose name is Gideon, out of her cage so she could freely wander the house.
我们第一次播出这个故事时，维罗妮卡40岁，已婚，有两个五岁的双胞胎男孩凯尔和卡梅伦，还有一个八岁的男孩丹尼尔。维罗妮卡最初见到这只金刚鹦鹉时不知道的是，它们可以活80岁——80岁。所以每天早上，她都会把名叫基甸（Gideon）的鸟从笼子里放出来，让它在屋里自由活动。
And get into things she shouldn't get into, like a baby-- climbing into laundry baskets and ripping up clothes, and taking the kids' Pokemon cards and ripping them to shreds, and pulling newspapers out of boxes.
它会去碰不该碰的东西，比如爬进洗衣篮撕碎衣服，抢走孩子们的宝可梦卡片并撕成碎片，把报纸从盒子里叼出来。
And so at breakfast, you've got three little kids there.
所以在早餐时，有三个小孩子在那里。
The kids will interact with each other. And Gideon will scream as loud as she can over their heads.
孩子们会相互互动。而基甸会在他们头顶上尽最大声嘶吼。
Now let's play a recording of Gideon for people at home.
现在，让我们为听众播放一段基甸的录音。
[PARROT SCREECHING]
[鹦鹉尖叫声]
[LAUGHING]
[笑声]
It sounds really loud.
听起来声音很大。
It's intolerable. It's a sound that you don't want to hear.
那简直无法忍受。那是不想听到的声音。
It sounds very dinosaur-like.
听起来很像恐龙。
Yeah. Well--
是的，好吧……
[PARROT SCREECHING]
[鹦鹉尖叫声]
[LAUGHING]
[笑声]
The word you just used was intolerable?
你刚才用的词是“无法忍受”？
It's the most unpleasant sound I think I have ever heard.
我想这是我听过最令人不快的声音。
But you've lived with this sound for 23 years.
但你和这个声音共同生活了23年。
I've lived with that sound for 23 years. It's in my dreams. It's wherever I go. It's in the kitchen. It's in the dining room. It's in my bedroom. And the kids have grown up with her. So they won't really notice it at first. But after about the fourth or fifth scream, they will start covering their ears and shouting back at the bird.
我确实和那个声音生活了23年。它在我的梦里，无论我走到哪儿，厨房、餐厅、卧室，它都在那里。孩子们从小就和它一起长大，所以起初他们并不在意，但通常在第四或第五声尖叫后，他们就会开始捂住耳朵，对那只鸟大喊。
[PARROT SCREECHING]
[鹦鹉尖叫声]
You stop it please?
你能停下来吗，求你了？
[PARROT SCREECHING]
[鹦鹉尖叫声]
Mommy, will you take me and put her in the tree?
妈妈，你能带我和它一起把它放进树里吗？
Now you tape little interviews with your kids about Gideon. Here's Cameron, who's five.
你还录过关于基甸的采访。这是五岁的卡梅伦。
Do you like having Gideon in the family?
你喜欢家里有基甸吗？
Not really.
不太喜欢。
Would you rather that she went somewhere else?
你希望它去别的地方吗？
Yeah. All the way to Sco-- to England. Because I don't want her to scream when we're watching TV.
是的，一直到英国。因为我看电视时不想让它尖叫。
Would you rather have a different kind of pet than Gideon?
你希望拥有除了基甸以外的其他宠物吗？
Yeah. A dog that is really nice and doesn't bite and doesn't bark.
是的，一只非常可爱、不咬人、不乱叫的狗。
But do you understand why mommy loves Gideon?
但你理解为什么妈妈爱基甸吗？
No.
不理解。
This is Kyle, the other twin, also five.
这是凯尔，另一个双胞胎，也是五岁。
One time she just almost bited off my thumb. That kind of scared me.
有一次它差点咬掉我的大拇指。那让我很害怕。
They're terrified of Gideon. If they're approached by her, they'll immediately scream and run away. They won't go near her now.
他们很怕基甸。如果基甸靠近，他们会立刻尖叫跑开。他们现在根本不靠近它。
And is that because Gideon is, in fact, a little dangerous? They're right to be a little scared?
这是因为基甸实际上有点危险吗？他们害怕是对的吗？
Well, Gideon's primary objective in life is to be my mate. And so every other person or creature that comes near me is a threat to our relationship. And my children are a very big threat to our relationship because we have physical contact with each other. She sees me carrying them and cooking for them and touching them and picking them up. And so she has a desire to kill them, basically. I mean, in the bird world, she would kill another predator or some intrusive love interest.
基甸人生中的主要目标是成为我的配偶。所以每一个靠近我的人或生物都是对我们关系的威胁。我的孩子们是巨大的威胁，因为我和他们有身体接触。它看着我抱着他们、为他们做饭、抚摸他们。所以它基本上有想杀死他们的欲望。在鸟类世界里，它会杀死其他捕食者或入侵的爱慕者。
Now after your kids were born and you saw how Gideon reacted to your children, and you saw how your children reacted to Gideon-- they were scared, that Gideon bit Kyle-- did it change your feelings about Gideon?
在你的孩子出生后，当你看到基甸对他们的反应，看到孩子们对基甸的反应——他们很害怕，基甸还咬了凯尔——这改变了你对基甸的感情吗？
I don't think anything can change my feelings about Gideon.
我不认为有什么能改变我对基甸的感情。
But if I had a dog that I loved, and then I had a new baby in the house, and the dog was hostile towards the baby, I wouldn't feel the same way about the dog. I would feel protective of my kid, which I'm sure you did.
但如果我有一条心爱的狗，家里又有了新宝宝，而狗对宝宝有敌意，我就不会对那条狗有同样的感情。我会保护我的孩子，我相信你也是。
Well, I do feel protective of the children, and I take certain steps to protect them from her, but I can't stop loving her because of her natural tendency to want to drive away competition.
我确实感到要保护孩子们，我也采取了措施保护他们不受它伤害，但我不能因为它赶走竞争对手的天性就不爱它。
As I said, this is a love story, and that Veronica knows Gideon is driving everybody else who she loves crazy. She loves the bird. The same monogamous feelings that make Gideon mean to everyone else make Gideon fantastically sweet to Veronica. Gideon watches her every move, cuddles with her, blushes. Gideon actually blushes when they play together. She is all that Gideon lives for, and it's hard to turn away from that.
如我所说，这是一个爱情故事。维罗妮卡知道基甸让其他她爱的人都快疯了。但她依然爱这只鸟。让基甸对别人刻薄的同样忠诚，也让它对维罗妮卡变得无比甜蜜。基甸关注她的一举一动，亲昵地与她拥抱、脸红——它们一起玩耍时基甸真的会脸红。维罗妮卡是基甸生活的全部，这很难转过身去。
[PARROT SCREECHING]
[鹦鹉尖叫声]
Thank you, Gideon. Veronica also worries that if she gave the bird away, the bird would die. They mate so fiercely that sometimes when their mate vanishes, that can happen.
谢谢你，基甸。维罗妮卡还担心如果她送走这只鸟，它会死去。它们的配偶关系非常强烈，有时当另一半消失，这种情况就会发生。
[PARROT SCREECHING]
[鹦鹉尖叫声]
I know, Gideon, it's upsetting.
我知道，基甸，这很难过。
[PARROT CHIRPING]
[鹦鹉鸣叫声]
And then there's this story. When Veronica was 18 and barely owned Gideon for a year, she took Gideon outside like she did every day. And Gideon flew away. Veronica hadn't been careful enough clipping her feathers. She was wrecked. Every night, Veronica cried herself to sleep. Every day she sat on the roof, watching the skies. After six days, a kid on his way to school spotted the bird.
还有这个故事。维罗妮卡18岁，养基甸不到一年时，她像往常一样带它出去。结果基甸飞走了。维罗妮卡剪羽不够小心。她崩溃了。每天晚上，维罗妮卡哭着入睡，每天坐在屋顶上凝望天空。六天后，一个上学的孩子发现了它。
And I quickly ran to where he said she was. And I saw her in probably the tallest tree and immediately scaled the tree, got all the way to the top. I was up about 50 feet. She was on the end of the branch, all the way out. And so I inched my way out.
我立刻跑到他说的位置，看到它在大概最高的树上，于是我立刻爬了上去。我爬了50英尺。它在树枝尽头，我一点点挪过去。
And about 3/4 of the way out-- I was only a foot away from her-- the branch snapped. And I fell straight down without hitting anything on the way. And just fell 50 feet and landed on my feet on hard ground. And I suffered a multiple compression fracture of my spine and I had a collapsed lung. I should have died, according to the orthopedic surgeon.
就在大概离它只有一英尺时，树枝断了。我没有任何遮挡直接摔了下去。坠落50英尺，双脚着地在坚硬的地面上。我的脊椎多处压缩性骨折，肺部塌陷。整形外科医生说我本该死掉的。
Do you think the fact that you nearly died trying to save Gideon is one of the things that makes it impossible for you to give Gideon up?
你认为你差点为了救基甸而死，是让你无法放弃它的原因之一吗？
That's something I've thought about. Yeah, it's quite possible. I feel like it's brought us closer. It's not a pleasant thing that happened, but I feel like she would have died out there.
这我也想过。是的，很有可能。我觉得这让我们走得更近了。虽然那不是什么愉快的事，但我感觉如果我不那么做，它一定死在那了。
You say that it brought us closer, but you're the only one who actually understands that you went out and you got injured trying to save Gideon. Gideon doesn't understand that.
你说这让你们更近了，但只有你自己明白你受了伤是为了救它，基甸并不理解。
No, she doesn't understand that, but I know she understands something. She's very bonded to me. She became so close to me at one point that her hormones produced an egg. And that's something that happens only between couples. So I know she feels something. I don't really need to know much more than that.
是的，它不理解，但我知道它明白一些事情。它和我羁绊很深。有一次它和我都亲近到它的荷尔蒙产生了一个蛋。那是情侣之间才会发生的事。所以我知道它感觉到了什么。我不一定要知道更多。
In the end, I think this is only partly a story about Veronica's love for Gideon. It's also a story about her family's love for her, that they put up with the bird. We all want to believe that the people who love us will at least accept the parts of us that are not so appealing. And in Veronica's case, the unappealing part just happens to have physical form and be a bird. Every day that her kids and her husband put up with that, they prove to her just how much they love her.
归根结底，我认为这不仅仅是维罗妮卡爱基甸的故事，这也是她家人爱她的故事——他们忍受着这只鸟。我们都想相信爱我们的人至少会接受我们身上不那么吸引人的部分。而维罗妮卡的情况里，那个“不吸引人的部分”恰好有实体且是一只鸟。她的孩子和丈夫每天忍受这一切，就是在向她证明他们有多爱她。
I just don't know why you had to buy her. How much bucks was she?
我就是不知道你为什么要买它。它花了多少钱？
She cost a lot of money.
它花了很多钱。
Like how much money?
比如多少钱？
She cost like $1,400.
它花了1400美元左右。
Whoa, just for a parrot? Why would they do that? Hi.
哇，就为了一只鹦鹉？为什么要这么做？嗨。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐]
The most remarkable thing, I think, about the phrase "I love you" is how rarely it's used literally to mean I love you, that I have a feeling of love for you. It's used much more often, I think, to mean 100 other things. Tell me that you love me. Or I need to get off the phone now. Or things are fine between us, right? Or yes, it's fine that we keep the parrot.
我认为“我爱你”这句话最了不起的一点是，它很少被字面意思使用，即我真的对你有爱。它更多被用来表示另外一百件事。比如：告诉我你爱我；或者，我现在得挂电话了；或者，我们之间没事对吧；或者，是的，我们留下这只鹦鹉没问题。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐]
Coming up, one of the best known stories from the bible, re-enacted with an armadillo, sort of. And what animal takes a licking and keeps on ticking? Answers in a minute, when our program continues.
接下来，圣经中最著名的故事之一，用犰狳重新演绎，算是吧。什么动物在历经折磨后依然生机勃勃？一分钟后揭晓，节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose some theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, "In Dog We Trust"-- stories of pets and the ways they function as actual members of our families and affect family dynamics. We first broadcast this show years ago. We have arrived at Act Three of our program. Act Three, "Resurrection."
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周我们都会选择一个主题，带来不同类型的故事。今天节目的主题是“忠于狗”——讲述关于宠物如何作为家庭成员发挥作用并影响家庭动态。我们几年前首次播出这期节目。现在进入第三幕：“复活”。
So earlier in today's show, David Sedaris talked about animals that his mom could and could not bring back to life. This is another story about what it is that animals can take the place of in our lives and in our homes. It's a piece of fiction from writer Brady Udall.
节目早些时候，大卫·塞达里斯谈到了他母亲能复活和不能复活的动物。这是另一个关于动物能在我们生活和家中取代什么位置的故事。这是一篇来自作家布雷迪·尤达尔的小说。
It was three days after our old man died that my brother, Donald, accomplished the most spectacular deed of his life. I wish I could have been there to see it. Donald taking the Greyhound down to Nogales all by himself, buying the baby armadillo for 800 pesos from a pie-faced Indian woman at the [INAUDIBLE] market, tucking the little thing under his arm like a football, and running the length of the pedestrian border station-- past the heat-struck tourists in their sombreros and loud socks, and the guards with their sidearms and walkie-talkies, pushing through the last steel-toothed turnstile, and sprinting like a madman into the heart of the Nogales slums.
老头子去世三天后，我弟弟唐纳德完成了他一生中最壮举的行动。真希望当时我在场。唐纳德独自一人乘灰狗巴士去诺加莱斯，从那个圆脸印第安女人手中用800比索买下了这只犰狳幼崽，把它像个足球一样夹在胳膊下，跑过步行边境站——越过那些被热坏了、戴着宽边帽和亮色短袜的游客，越过带着配枪和对讲机的守卫，冲过最后一道钢齿旋转门，像个疯子一样冲进诺加莱斯的贫民窟。
It was his proudest moment, though it did take him the rest of the day and half the night of wandering among the hookers and street corner punks to find a bus that would bring him back to Aho, where we lived. There he was, after I came home from hours of frantic searching, sitting stiff-backed on the couch, beaming. The little armadillo was rooting at the crotch of his pants, and Donald's pink sweating face had screwed itself up with such a grin of utter self-satisfaction.
那是他最自豪的时刻，虽然他花了剩下的大半天和半个晚上在妓女和街头流氓中徘徊，才找到一辆车把他带回我们居住的阿霍。当我结束疯狂的寻找回到家时，他正坐在沙发上，脊背挺直，满面春风。小犰狳在他裤裆里钻来钻去，唐纳德那张汗津津的粉色脸庞露出了极度满足的笑容。
Donald ended up giving the armadillo to me. A present, he said, something to make me feel better. I thanked him, took the armadillo which clawed at my T-shirt like a cat, and gave it a little squeeze. What else could I do?
唐纳德最终把犰狳给了我。他说这是个礼物，让我感觉好点。我感谢了他，接过那只像猫一样抓我T恤的犰狳，捏了它一下。我还能怎么办？
My father had worked as a janitor for 21 years. But he was also a reader of books, a scholar, if it is possible to be both a scholar and a sixth grade dropout. And one of his favorite subjects was zoology. He could bore you into a coma with what he knew about the great horned owl or the common mealworm or the laughing hyenas of Africa.
我父亲做了21年的清洁工。但他也是个读书人，如果一个小学没毕业的人能称得上学者的话。他最喜欢的科目之一是动物学。他能让你听得昏昏欲睡，关于大角猫头鹰、普通粉虫或非洲斑鬣狗的知识他了如指掌。
But of all the beasts of the animal kingdom, he loved and admired the humble armadillo most. Nope, not the smartest or the prettiest, he would say when one of them scattered across the highway in front of our old LeMans. But the hardiest, you see what I'm saying, the most resourceful.
但在所有野兽中，他最爱也最崇拜卑微的犰狳。“没，”当它们在我们旧勒芒车前横穿公路时，他会说，“它不是最聪明也不是最漂亮的，但它是最坚韧的，你明白我的意思吗，最有韧性的。”
He often promised he would get us an armadillo for a pet, but he died before he could come through-- an end-all heart attack standing in line at the grocery store. I was 17, Donald 19. Our mother, a Guatemalan migrant worker who had married my father under the impression he would one day be a rich man who could buy her a Cadillac and a house with a swimming pool, had run off when we were babies. So it was just the two of us now.
他经常承诺要给我们弄一只犰狳当宠物，但他没能实现就去世了——在杂货店排队时突发心脏病。当时我17岁，唐纳德19岁。我们的母亲是个危地马拉移民劳工，嫁给我父亲时以为他有一天会发大财，买给她一辆凯迪拉克和带游泳池的房子，但她在我们还是婴儿时就跑了。所以现在只剩下我们兄弟俩。
It took me about a week to get over the shock, and then I did what I had to. I dropped out of school, started working full time pouring concrete for Hasenpfeffer's and moved Donald and me to a cheaper apartment near the [? McComb ?] and Sons wrecking yard, where Donald could watch the cars getting pulverized from our window. We got money from the state that paid for Donald's medication, but the rest was up to me.
花了一周时间我才从震惊中走出来，然后我做了该做的事。我退了学，开始在Hasenpfeffer做全职混凝土浇筑工，搬到离回收场较近的便宜公寓，唐纳德可以从窗口看车被压碎。我们有国家的补助金支付唐纳德的药物，其余的都靠我。
Donald was really something else. What could be done with a guy who ate his own earwax, who carried a maroon mini bible in the band of his underpants, and read random scriptures out loud at inappropriate times? Who could be sashaying about the room one minute, doing a dead-on impression of Sammy Davis, Jr., and the next be downstairs in the closet grunting like a pig and trying to tear his hair out?
唐纳德真是个奇葩。一个吃自己耳垢、把小圣经揣在内裤松紧带里、在不合适的场合大声读经文的人，你拿他怎么办？上一秒还在房间里走猫步模仿小萨米·戴维斯，下一秒就在楼下衣柜里像猪一样咕哝着试图拔头发。
From a distance, you wouldn't have been able to tell him from any other teenager. He had relatively good hygiene, did not usually talk to himself in public, and was something of a handsome devil, with his dark hair hanging down over pale green eyes. Sometimes I would take him to a party or a dance with me and the girls would flock around us. He could be as charming as Hugh Hefner in short bursts before he'd have to run off and hide in the bathroom.
远看，你根本分不出他和普通少年有什么区别。他卫生状况良好，在公共场合一般不自言自语，还是个美男子，深色头发垂在淡绿色眼睛上。有时我带他去聚会或跳舞，女孩们会围着他。他在那几分钟里能像休·赫夫纳一样迷人，然后就得逃跑躲进厕所。
I remember once when I was nine or 10, and we were playing in the back yard. He kept pestering me, saying, I am the Indian. You are the cowboy. OK? I told him to shut his trap. I was busy building a cave for my army men. He wouldn't give up. Me Indian, you cowboy. Okey-dokey? Over and over.
我记得九岁十岁时，我们在后院玩。他一直缠着我：“我是印第安人，你是牛仔，好吗？”我叫他闭嘴。我正忙着给我的士兵们建洞穴。他不放弃：“我是印第安人，你是牛仔，好吗？”一遍又一遍。
Damn it, Donald, you freak, I hollered. Do whatever you want, but just shut up for a second. I'm not a freak, he said, sticking his chin out. All right then, I said. The next time I looked up, Donald was on top of the doghouse with a bow and arrow set my father had bought for him at a garage sale. He had the arrow notched and pulled back to his ear, just like the Indians we saw on TV.
“妈的，唐纳德，你这个怪胎，”我吼道，“想做什么就做什么，但闭上你的嘴。我不是怪胎，”他伸出下巴说。“行行行，”我说。下一次我抬头时，唐纳德正站在狗屋顶上，拿着父亲在跳蚤市场买的弓箭。他像电视里看到的印第安人一样，搭好箭，拉满弦。
I hadn't noticed before, but now I saw that he had taken off his shirt and tucked it in the elastic of his shorts so it looked like he was wearing a loincloth, and had used a little blood from the scab on his elbow to make fiendish red streaks across his face. He was doing it perfect, really, just like a TV Indian.
之前没注意，现在我发现他脱了衬衫塞进短裤松紧带里，看起来像穿了腰布，还用了胳膊上伤疤渗出的血，在脸上抹出了狰狞的红杠。他做得真完美，就像电视里的印第安人。
I didn't believe he would really shoot me, so I just sat there like a jackass, my hands full of dirt. I didn't see him let go of the bowstring, but I certainly did hear the fop the arrow made when it hit me in the chest dead center. More from the surprise than anything, I fell flat on my back. It was only a target arrow, but it pierced my sternum just enough to stand up right from my chest, waving around sluggishly like a reed in a river.
我不信他真的会射我，所以像个蠢货一样坐在那，手里满是泥土。我没看见他松开弓弦，但我确实听到了那记箭撞击胸部正中的声音。比起惊吓，更多是因为冲击，我向后倒去。那只是目标练习用的箭，但刚好刺入我的胸骨，在那里晃动着。
I lay in the grass and stared up at the neon yellow fletching of the arrow. My hands were still full of dirt. Donald jumped down from the doghouse and stood over me. He was smiling an odd, satisfied smile, as if he was expecting to be congratulated on his marksmanship. He looked down at me for a long time before he gently put his hand around the shaft of the arrow without pulling it out. He said, right smack dab in the heart, white man.
我躺在草地上，盯着那荧光黄的箭羽。手里还是满手泥土。唐纳德从狗屋跳下来站在我上方。他露出了怪异、满足的微笑，仿佛在期待因箭法高超而受褒奖。他盯着我看许久，轻轻把手放在箭杆上却没拔出来。他说：“正中红心，白人。”
I told Donald I wanted him to name the armadillo. After several days of deliberation, he decided to name it after Otis, the happy drunk on The Andy Griffith Show, who our father had resembled in almost eerie detail. I'd gotten used to taking care of Donald alone. I had no choice. But Otis was a different story.
我告诉唐纳德让他给犰狳取名。经过几天深思熟虑，他决定用《安迪·格里菲斯秀》里那个快乐酒鬼奥蒂斯的名字，那个人跟我父亲长得惊人地像。我已经习惯单独照顾唐纳德了。我没得选。但奥蒂斯是另一回事。
First of all, Otis smelled. He gave off a musky odor that intensified whenever he was nervous or hungry. And no matter if we scrubbed him raw with industrial soap and water, the smell would come back in an hour or so.
首先，奥蒂斯很臭。每当它紧张或饥饿时，就会散发出一种麝香味。不管我们用工业皂水怎么用力刷它，味道过一个小时就又回来了。
And then there was the furniture. Armadillos are burrowing animals. This is something I learned from my father. And in the confines of our small apartment, Otis didn't have many opportunities to burrow.
还有家具问题。犰狳是穴居动物，这是我从父亲那里学到的。在我们局促的公寓里，奥蒂斯没多少打洞的机会。
Instead, he would march through the house like a tiny gray tank and move the furniture around. He'd waddle into the living room, put his blunt forehead against one of the legs of the coffee table and bear down, inching it around the room, his little squirrel claws scrabbling on the wood floor. At least once a week, he would crawl between the mattress and box springs of my bed and take a dump.
相反，它会像个小坦克一样穿过房子，移动家具。它大摇大摆地走进客厅，用钝额头抵住咖啡桌的一条腿发力，在木地板上一点点推着走，爪子抓挠地板。每周至少一次，它会钻进床垫和弹簧床之间拉屎。
My father was right about armadillos. They are hardy, they are resourceful-- and if Otis is typical, they're as dumb as donkey crap. Sometimes in the course of his incessant apartment wandering, Otis would find himself trapped in a corner and would spend the rest of the evening attempting to claw his way out.
父亲说得对，犰狳确实坚韧、机智——如果奥蒂斯是个标本的话，它们也笨得像驴。有时在公寓里无休止的游荡中，奥蒂斯会被困在角落，余下的一整个晚上它都会试图爪挖出路。
Otis was technically my pet. But Donald cared for him, worried over and tormented and teased him, then made up with tearful professions of regret and affection. While I was away at work, they would do things together. Donald would carry Otis around outside, conversing with him, rooting in the weeds in the vacant lot, searching for earthworms or crickets for Otis's dinner.
奥蒂斯名义上是我的宠物，但唐纳德照顾它，担心、折磨和逗弄它，然后又流着泪表示后悔和爱意。我上班时，他们在一起做各种事。唐纳德会带奥蒂斯在外面走，跟它谈心，在空地上翻找蚯蚓或蟋蟀作为奥蒂斯的晚餐。
Sometimes Donald would hide behind the recliner, and when Otis passed by would jump out and shout in a high soprano wail, "Look out, Otis!" Poor Otis would spring two feet into the air like a startled cat, his leathery body twisting, his claws clutching at nothing. And once he'd landed, he'd scurry into the hallway looking back over his shoulder, embarrassment in those little piggy eyes.
有时唐纳德躲在躺椅后，奥蒂斯经过时他会跳出来尖叫：“小心，奥蒂斯！”可怜的奥蒂斯会像受惊的猫一样跳两英尺高，皮革身体扭动，爪子胡乱抓挠。落地后，它会缩回走廊，回头看，猪一样的眼睛里充满了尴尬。
This kind of living arrangement was no boost to my social life, I can tell you. If I ever wanted to bring a girl home, I figured I'd have some difficulty explaining why the apartment smelled like a bear's den, why the furniture was strewn around, and why my brother was naked and hiding behind the couch, waiting to scare the daylights out of an armadillo.
这种生活状况对我的社交生活毫无帮助，我可以告诉你。如果我想带个女孩回家，我不知道该怎么解释为什么公寓闻起来像熊窝，为什么家具东倒西歪，为什么我哥哥光着身子躲在沙发后面等着吓那只犰狳。
It took five years before I found someone I loved enough to bring home. Allison was good about everything, told me I was a saint and a Christian to be taking care of Donald. She was so wonderful and beautiful and good-smelling, I could barely stand it. Eventually, I proposed to her, after which I went home to talk to Donald.
五年后我才找到一个深爱到想带回家的人。艾莉森对此很宽容，说我照顾唐纳德是个圣人、是个基督徒。她那么完美、美丽、清香，我简直无法抗拒。最终，我向她求婚，然后回家去找唐纳德谈话。
It was springtime in the desert, the smell of cactus blossoms everywhere. And I was so full of love and desire I could barely see straight. Allison and I had decided that we would get an apartment nearby. With my new promotion at Hasenpfeffer's and Allison's job at the county courthouse, we could afford our own place-- and with the help of the government's support, Donald.
那是沙漠的春天，仙人掌花香四溢。我心中充满爱与渴望。艾莉森和我决定在附近租个公寓。凭借我在Hasenpfeffer的新晋升和艾莉森在法院的工作，我们买得起自己的房子——在政府补助的帮助下，也能安顿唐纳德。
Donald would be all right as long as we checked on him daily, made sure he was taking his medication, and occasionally washed down the place with ammonia so the smell wouldn't bother the neighbors. I have to admit, the thought of escaping from Donald and Otis and that cave of an apartment was almost as enticing as the thought of being together with Allison.
唐纳德只要我们每天探望，确保他吃药，偶尔用氨水清洗屋子不让邻居抱怨就行。我得承认，逃离唐纳德和奥蒂斯及那个洞穴般的公寓的念头，和与艾莉森在一起的念头同样诱人。
At home, when I sat Donald down to explain things to him, I could barely get a word out. I stuttered and stammered, kept wiping my mouth. When I finally made things clear, Donald whipped out his mini bible and frantically paged through it, but couldn't seem to come up with anything-- the first time I'd ever seen him at a loss for a scripture. He yanked at his hair and ground his teeth together until they squeaked.
在家，当我坐下来跟唐纳德解释时，几乎说不出话。我口吃着，不停擦嘴。最终说明白后，唐纳德掏出他的小圣经疯狂翻阅，却什么也找不到——这是我第一次见他找不到经文。他拔头发，磨牙磨得吱吱作响。
Finally without saying anything, he snatched up Otis who had been napping under one of the couch cushions and went into the laundry room, slamming the door behind him. I felt like kicking that door down and wringing his neck. Couldn't you at least try to be happy for me, to think of somebody other than himself for one minute? I wanted only to be with Allison, and I hated Donald for making it so difficult-- hated him for years of responsibility and obligation and lost opportunities-- hated him in the way only a brother can hate a brother.
最后，他什么也没说，抢起沙发垫下午睡的奥蒂斯就进了洗衣房，关上门。我真想踹开门掐死他。他就不能哪怕试着为我高兴一点吗？能不能哪怕一分钟为别人考虑而不是他自己？我只想要和艾莉森在一起，我恨唐纳德把事情弄得这么难——恨他多年来的责任、义务和失去的机会——以一种兄弟对兄弟那种特有的恨意恨他。
I took a few steps toward the stairwell to leave. I didn't care. I was going to stay at Allison's, my first night ever away from Donald, when I heard a splashing noise from inside the apartment. The laundry room door was locked and I shouted Donald's name, but got no response.
我向楼梯走了几步准备离开。我不在乎了。我打算在艾莉森家过夜，这是我第一次离开唐纳德，却听到公寓内传来泼水声。洗衣房门锁着，我喊唐纳德的名字，没人回应。
I tried to kick in the door, which was made of something like cardboard. My foot went right through it. Once I had my leg free, I looked through the splintered hole and could see Donald hunched over the overflowing utility sink, both arms submerged up to his biceps. The back of his neck was purple and pulsing, full of angry blood. And it took me only a moment to understand. He was trying to drown Otis.
我试图踢开那扇纸板门，脚直接穿透了。把腿拔出来后，我透过破洞看到唐纳德蜷在溢水的洗衣槽上，双臂没入水中直到二头肌。他脖子后面涨得紫色跳动，充满愤怒。我瞬间明白了一切，他在试图淹死奥蒂斯。
I unlocked the door and grabbed him from behind, but he resisted me, grunting and plunging Otis deeper into the water. I wrestled him out into the living room, where we fell sideways against the couch. Donald twisted away from me and stood up, the water dripping off his elbows, forming a puddle around his shoes.
我开锁冲进去从背后抓住他，他抵抗着，咕哝着把奥蒂斯往水里按。我把他拽进客厅，我们倒在沙发上。唐纳德扭开我站起来，水从他肘部滴落，鞋边积成一滩。
Otis was curled up in a ball, just like when he slept. And Donald began to shiver so badly that he lost his grip, and let Otis' body slide out of his hands and hit the floor with a wet slap. Donald's face twisted into a mask of concentrated grief. See, he wept, see what I did?
奥蒂斯缩成一个球，像睡觉时那样。唐纳德颤抖得太厉害以至于脱了手，让奥蒂斯的尸体滑落，湿漉漉地摔在地板上。唐纳德脸上布满极度悲伤。“看，”他哭道，“看我做了什么？”
Looking at my brother, I felt all the parts of me that had been opening up since I had met Allison collapse on each other like so many empty rooms. It would have to be me and Donald, brothers, inseparable, no one else allowed. I don't remember if I looked away or if it was as sudden as it seemed, but one moment Otis was a sad, wet corpse, as dead as an armadillo could be. And the next, he was huffing and twitching and scrabbling to his feet.
看着弟弟，我觉得自遇到艾莉森后内心刚刚开启的部分全都像空房间一样坍塌了。我们必须一起，兄弟俩，分不开，谁都不许介入。我不记得是我没看还是它发生得太突然，反正前一刻奥蒂斯还是个湿漉漉的尸体，死得不能再透了。下一刻，它就抽动着四肢站了起来。
Donald let out an arching shriek, which sent Otis zigzagging into the kitchen where a mad chase ensued-- Donald slipping and flailing, knocking over chairs and pulling down the drapes, still choking and sobbing, now with relief. He finally herded Otis under the table. And once he had pulled him out, he held him up, his fingers locked in a death grip around his little body, and cried, "Otis is resurrected. Otis is resurrected."
唐纳德发出一声刺耳的尖叫，奥蒂斯Zigzag（之字形）跑进厨房，随即是一场疯狂的追逐——唐纳德摔倒乱挥，打翻椅子拉下窗帘，依然哽咽哭泣，这次是出于如释重负。他最后把奥蒂斯赶到桌下。拽出来后，他死死锁住它小小的身体，大喊：“奥蒂斯复活了！奥蒂斯复活了！”
A fair trade. Donald got his armadillo back and I got to marry Allison. Never again did Donald show any sign of jealousy or resentment. He was the best man at our wedding, read a long section from Zephaniah at the reception, and even bought us a gift-- a book called Hot Sex for Cold Fish.
一场公平交易。唐纳德找回了犰狳，我娶到了艾莉森。唐纳德再没显露出任何嫉妒或怨恨。他在我们婚礼上做伴郎，在招待会上读了一长段《西番雅书》，还送了我们一件礼物——一本叫《冷鱼的热辣性爱》的书。
Things went well those first few years. We saved up enough to buy the concrete business from old Hasenpfeffer, who retired to ride his Harley around the continent. And Donald and Otis seemed to thrive together. We stopped in to visit as often as we could. Allison cooked dinner for them on Tuesdays and Thursdays. And we paid a house cleaning service to scrub the apartment down every week, put the furniture back in place, and steamed the carpets.
起初几年一切顺利。我们存够钱从老Hasenpfeffer手里买下了混凝土生意，他退休去骑哈雷摩托环游大陆了。唐纳德和奥蒂斯看起来相处得很好。我们尽可能去探望。艾莉森周二和周四为他们做晚饭。我们还雇了清洁服务每周打扫公寓，把家具归位，蒸洗地毯。
Donald had his first episode one night while I was in Phoenix at a heavy equipment auction. They found him digging up the lawn in front of the city First Bank, blabbering about how difficult it was to find high grade earthworms on the south end of town. When the cops tried to approach him, he pelted them with dirt clods and threatened to eat a fist full of worms if they got any closer. He spent most of the night in the holding tank before Sheriff Brasky figured out who he was and gave me a call.
我在凤凰城参加重型设备拍卖会时，唐纳德第一次发病。他们发现他在市政第一银行草坪上挖坑，胡言乱语说着城南很难找到高等级蚯蚓。警察试图靠近时，他朝他们投掷土块，威胁说如果他们再靠近就要吃下一把蚯蚓。他在拘留所待了大半夜，直到警长Brasky认出他是谁并打给我。
A few months later, Donald climbed an old elm at the city park, which branched out over a sidewalk. He managed to pee on a few passersby before the groundskeeper knocked him off a branch with a well-thrown rake. We took him to a doctor, who adjusted his medication and suggested that Donald be put in a home where he could get the care and attention he needed, where he could socialize with somebody besides an armadillo.
几个月后，唐纳德爬上了公园的一棵老榆树，树枝伸向人行道。他在几名路人头上撒尿，直到场地管理员用耙子把他从树枝上捅了下来。我们带他看了医生，调整了药物并建议把唐纳德送进疗养院，那里他可以得到照顾，也可以接触犰狳以外的人。
I brought up the subject with Donald, but he told me he would rather die than give up Otis and go live in a house with a bunch of half-wits and knuckleheads. The only other option, we knew, was taking in Donald and Otis ourselves. Allison was eight months pregnant with our second baby. The business was really starting to take off. It just wasn't a good time, we told ourselves. We might be able to work something out in a few months when things had settled down. By the end of the summer, Donald was dead.
我向唐纳德提过，但他告诉我他宁愿死也不愿放弃奥蒂斯去和一群白痴一起住。唯一的办法就是把唐纳德和奥蒂斯接过来。艾莉森那时怀着我们的第二个孩子，八个月了。事业正蒸蒸日上。这不是好时机，我们这样告诉自己。我们想着再过几个月等事情稳定下来再解决。夏天结束时，唐纳德死了。
The call came in the middle of the night like they always do. Sheriff Brasky told me that Donald had been hit by a car on 87 near the refinery. He had run through traffic completely naked, dodging cars and sprinting down the median until an old couple in a minivan clipped him with their bumper, knocking him over a temporary still divider and onto a concrete platform where he was partially impaled by a jutting piece of rebar. He bled to death before the ambulance arrived.
电话像往常一样在半夜响起。警长Brasky告诉我唐纳德在87号公路靠近精炼厂的地方被车撞了。他全身赤裸穿过车流，在中央隔离带躲闪奔跑，直到一对老夫妻开的面包车把他的头撞到临时分流柱上，他掉到了混凝土平台上，被一块外露的钢筋部分刺穿。救护车赶到前他流血过多死亡。
After I went to the hospital to identify his body, I drove out to the accident site. For half an hour, I combed both sides of the highway without a flashlight until I found Otis cowering under a piece of discarded plywood. His left foreleg was mangled, nearly torn from his body. And he was bleeding from the soft flesh of his belly.
去医院认尸后，我开车去了事故现场。半小时内，我没带手电筒搜遍了公路两边，终于发现奥蒂斯蜷缩在一块丢弃的胶合板下。它左前腿残缺，几乎脱离身体。腹部娇嫩的皮肉在流血。
I drove him over to the only veterinarian in town, Larry Oleander, and pounded on the door until he answered. Larry was an old retired cowboy with a glass eyeball and a dent in his head where a mule had kicked him. Jesus, Geronimo, Christ, he said. It was 4 o'clock in the morning.
我把它带到镇上唯一的兽医Larry Oleander那里，用力敲门。Larry是个退休的老牛仔，有一只玻璃假眼，头上因为被骡子踢过有个凹坑。“耶稣，杰罗尼莫，基督，”他说，当时是凌晨4点。
I held Otis out to him and he said, what you have there is an armadillo. Fix him up, I said. Son, he said, I don't know what you think-- Do it. Larry Oleander peered up at me. He sighed and held the screen door open. Come the hell on in.
我举起奥蒂斯说，“这是只犰狳。”“修好它，”我说。“孩子，”他说，“我不知道你以为……”“做吧。”Larry Oleander打量着我，叹了口气把纱门推开。“进来吧，真他妈的。”
Larry amputated Otis' leg, stitched up the wound on his underside, and bandaged him until he looked like one big wad of gauze. When I tried to pay him, he waved his hand in front of my face, took a slug off a bottle of vodka he kept under the operating table. Jesus, Richard, just promise me you'll never make a peep about this to anybody.
Larry锯掉了奥蒂斯的腿，缝好了它腹部的伤口，用纱布把它包得像个大包裹。我想付钱时，他摆摆手，拿起操作台下的伏特加喝了一大口。“耶稣，理查德，答应我永远别跟任何人提这事。”
I took Otis home, and he has been part of our family ever since. Over the last few years, I've added on a wing to the house just for him. He has a room with a skylight and two bay windows, his own pillow bed to sleep under, and a bunch of old furniture to push around. As far as I'm aware, he is the only three-legged armadillo on Earth with his own personal wading pool.
我把奥蒂斯带回家，从那以后它就成了我们家的一份子。过去几年，我专门给它加盖了一个侧屋。它有一个带天窗和两个凸窗的房间，它专属的枕头床，还有一堆旧家具供它推搡。据我所知，它是地球上唯一拥有一人份戏水池的三条腿犰狳。
Allison is not thrilled about having an armadillo in her home, never has been. But she knows it's important to me. The kids-- we have four of them now-- can't stand Otis either. They want another pet, some kind of happy, slobbering dog or an albino snake to impress their friends.
艾莉森从没因为家里有只犰狳而感到兴奋，从来没有。但她知道这对我很重要。孩子们——我们现在有四个了——也受不了奥蒂斯。他们想要别的宠物，某种快乐、流口水的狗或者白化蛇来炫耀。
Otis is not only real, real, dumb, they argue, but also smells like doodoo. They're not sure which is worse. I tell them they are correct. They'll get no disagreement from me, but Otis is our pet and we're going to love him no matter what.
他们辩称，奥蒂斯不仅极其愚笨，而且闻起来像臭大便。他们不确定哪个更糟。我告诉他们是对的。他们不会从我这里得到异议，但奥蒂斯是我们的宠物，不管怎样我们都会爱它。
I try not to let myself forget how blessed I am-- my beautiful family, my dream house up in the hills, a successful business that pretty much runs without me. I am happy and satisfied most of the time. But every once in a while, maybe once or twice a year, something will come over me-- a dark mood that I can't shake, usually at night when everyone is asleep and the house is quiet. And I'll get Otis out from under his pillow bed and take him upstairs.
我努力不让自己忘记我是多么受上帝保佑——美丽的家庭，山坡上的梦想家园，一个基本无需我介入就能运转的成功企业。大多数时间我都很幸福满足。但偶尔，一年一两次，一种黑暗情绪会笼罩我——通常是夜里大家都睡着了、房子安静的时候。我会把奥蒂斯从枕头下弄出来带上楼。
I run a bath, sitting on the lip of the tub, holding him close to my chest the way he likes it. Usually I just let him paddle around, but sometimes when the tub is almost overflowing, I take him firmly in both hands and plunge him into the water. There's not a clock in the bathroom, so I count one alligator, two alligator, three alligator. This is how I count off the seconds. Otis struggles like a tiny lion for the first two or three minutes, writhing and spasming wildly, sending up a boiling foam of bubbles, fighting and scratching with everything he's got, and I hate myself for what I'm doing to him.
我放好澡水，坐在浴缸边，把它紧紧贴在胸口，像它喜欢的那样。通常我只是让它戏水，但有时当水快漫出时，我会双手握紧它把它按进水里。浴室没时钟，所以我计数：一只鳄鱼，两只鳄鱼，三只鳄鱼。这是我计算秒数的方式。奥蒂斯前两三分钟像只小狮子一样挣扎，扭动痉挛，激起沸腾的泡沫，用尽一切力量挣扎抓挠，我为自己正在做的事恨透了自己。
Usually between the fourth and fifth minute is when he starts to lose his will and his thrashing weakens, as he gradually curls up on himself like a flower dying, and goes utterly still. This is always the hardest part for me. The urge to pull him out is almost unbearable, but I go five or 10 seconds longer than the last time. One alligator, two alligator, three alligator, four alligator, five alligator-- until I can't stand it anymore.
通常在第四到五分钟，它的意志开始动摇，挣扎减弱，逐渐像朵枯萎的花一样自我蜷缩，变得彻底安静。这是我最痛苦的部分。我想把它拉出来的冲动强烈得不可忍受，但我还是比上次多忍了五到十秒。一只鳄鱼，两只鳄鱼……直到我再也忍不下去。
I lift him out and he lies there in my hands like a deflated soccer ball. And I'm sick with dread knowing that this time, I've taken it too far. I've killed him. I stare down at him and wait, hardly blinking, wait for that first twitch or jerk, for his nostrils to flare with life. And usually there's an almost imperceptible shudder from under his hard shell, a stirring. And his tail will begin to vibrate like a piano wire. And he slowly, hesitantly, opens up and stretches himself, clawing the air and coughing like a newborn.
我把它提出来，它像个瘪掉的足球一样躺在我手里。我因恐惧而恶心，知道这次我太过分了。我杀了它。我盯着它等待，几乎不眨眼，等待那第一次抽动，等待它的鼻孔因生命气息而张开。通常在硬壳下会有难以觉察的一丝颤抖。它的尾巴会像钢琴弦一样开始震动。它缓慢、犹豫地张开身体，抓挠空气，像新生儿一样咳嗽。
Sitting on the edge of the bathtub with Otis wet and dripping in my arms, I'm always overcome with the same vision-- Donald clutching a newly revived Otis, his face slick with tears, transformed from a man twisted inside out with grief to someone awestruck at the realization that our worst mistakes can be retrieved-- that death can be traded in for life, that what has been destroyed can be made whole again.
坐在浴缸边，抱着湿漉漉的奥蒂斯，我总会看到同样的景象——唐纳德紧抓着新复活的奥蒂斯，脸庞满是泪水，从一个被悲伤扭曲的人变成了一个因意识到“我们最严重的错误也能挽回”而感到敬畏的人——意识到死亡可以被交换成生命，曾经被摧毁的东西可以再次完整。
With a sudden surge, Otis struggles to get out of my lap. He is an armadillo and there is exploring to do. I let him down and watch him slide around on the linoleum and try to push the toilet off its base, and I feel a small, bitter joy lodge in my heart. Otis is resurrected, I whisper.
奥蒂斯猛地挣扎想要从我腿上下来。它是一只犰狳，还有很多地方要去探索。我放它下来，看它在地板砖上滑行，试图把厕所推离基座，心中涌起一股微小而苦涩的快乐。我低语：“奥蒂斯复活了。”
I carry him to his room and make sure he is comfortable under his pillow bed. And only then will I be able to walk peacefully through the dark, quiet halls of my home, kiss each of my children good night, and lie down next to my wife to sleep.
我把它抱回房间，确认它在枕头下躺得舒服。只有那时，我才能平和地走过家中黑暗安静的走廊，亲吻每个孩子晚安，躺在妻子身边入睡。
Brady Udall. His short story "Otis Is Resurrected" was first published in Story Magazine. It is a work of fiction. No armadillos were harmed in the making of this radio story.
布雷迪·尤达尔。他的短篇小说《奥蒂斯复活了》首次发表于《故事》杂志。这是一部虚构作品。该广播故事的制作过程中未伤害任何犰狳。
Our program was produced today by Alex Blumberg and myself, and Susan Burton, Blue Chevigny, and Julie Snyder. Our technical director is Matt Tierney, production help from Alvin Melathe. In the years since we first broadcast our story in Act Two about Veronica Chater's macaw, she has published a memoir, which includes "Life with a Macaw." It's called Waiting for the Apocalypse.
节目今天由亚历克斯·布隆伯格、我本人、苏珊·伯顿、蓝色·切维尼和朱莉·斯奈德制作。技术总监是马特·蒂尔尼，阿尔文·梅拉斯提供了制作协助。自我们几年前首次播出Act Two关于维罗妮卡·查特那只金刚鹦鹉的故事以来，她出版了一本回忆录，其中包括《与金刚鹦鹉的生活》。书名是《等待启示录》。
Special thanks today to the student staff of WWVU in Morgantown in West Virginia, to Mary Zimmerman, to Larry Josephson, to Deborah and Stephen Diggs. Our website, ThisAmericanLife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
特别感谢西弗吉尼亚州摩根敦WWVU的学生员工，感谢玛丽·齐默尔曼、拉里·约瑟夫森、黛博拉和斯蒂芬·迪格斯。我们的网站：ThisAmericanLife.org。《美国生活》由公共广播交流平台PRX传送给公共广播电台。
Thanks as always to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, it's weird. We've known each other for years, but every time I try to give him a hug, he starts yelling
一如既往感谢我们的联合创始人托瑞·马拉蒂亚先生。你知道，这很奇怪。我们认识多年了，但每次我试图拥抱他，他就开始大喊：
Somebody help me. This stranger is trying to hurt me and I don't know why.
“谁来帮帮我。这个陌生人想伤害我，我不知道为什么。”
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带给大家更多《美国生活》的故事。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐]